thing is like i mean we have so much in
common i think
in our comedy um you know just that
we're crossovers that people
[ __ ] hate that we're succeeding in
comedy
[Music]
they want to say that we're not [ __ ]
funny and and like
and and whatever you know but we both
had comedy specials in showtime yeah you
know
and you know to be fair i think it's
safe to say that we both did specials
like you know pretty early on you know
like where where i'm not bombed that i
did
the one special and and when i did my
first special showtime
it was as good as it could have i
couldn't it was the best [ __ ]
the best i had the best i was capable of
this time you know
and now i look back on it and now it's
like [ __ ] i've come so far since i agree
you know i agree like if i put out what
i'm doing now would crush that sure
but you know the way i look at it's like
i had the opportunity
i auditioned several times for it they
passed me for the special
so i was like well this is where i'm at
right now how cool would it be you know
because i'll be doing comedy for the
next 30 40 years how cool would it be if
you could go back
and see say dave chappelle when he
wasn't ready to see his special
you're like oh that's dope to see that
and then where he's at now that's
right that was my kind of frame of mind
going into it right
and like and then obviously people can
be like oh you're you're
you're special compared to chappelle's
with [ __ ] i'm like dude i'm doing comedy
for
two weeks yeah what do you want me to do
you're comparing me to that guy
right yeah and and when whatever dude
like
my [ __ ] was was so filled with like
[ __ ] that nobody would ever admit you
know they're in their right mind like
and and that that's what what what's
[ __ ] up about it
no one's hating on you or me that is
successful
no like the reason why their anger comes
from that place is because
somewhere along the line they think they
got shafted and they see
the success you're having the tickets
you're selling and the fan base that you
have and they want that and that's where
the anger comes
so when i see that i'm like i get it man
i get it dude yeah
i get it sure right it's a dude and and
i i
thought that when i had my own special
come out on show time i was like oh dude
well then everyone's just gonna be so
shut the [ __ ] up now i'm steve was gonna
be established as a stand-up comedian
i'm gonna be like
moving up to theaters it's gonna be
crazy my life's gonna explode yep
it got worse special came out nothing
changed
it gave the the the haters something to
focus on
nothing changed yeah nothing nothing
whatsoever like uh
i wasn't selling more tickets i was
doing exactly the [ __ ] same
and you know it seemed that
very few people like commented about
having even seen it you know
it was just like it's strange right it
didn't get like i mean i guess because
the media is so fragmented you know like
it's a different world now it's just a
different world when it comes to
specials
right so many of them but then also to
this point you can relate to this it's
like
you know you're you're not posting the
countless time you put into
doing that special and how many shows
you do on the road like
for ca i think uh two years ago this
previous year before all this coverage
should happen
see goes you're you did the most cities
out of any comic we have man
so no one they don't see that grind that
goes in
to get into that special it's so funny
when you put it that way but
they also don't see how you're bringing
home a check every time you practice
yeah that is true yeah
it's a beautiful it's a beautiful system
the way that it works
but as i got into developing my
my follow-up you know at the hour
right like and uh from when i taped the
first special
to when it came out what was it like i
don't know like
five months maybe six months so like i
started getting into new material
you know so that i i like the transition
wasn't i'm starting from scratch
you know as soon as i taped it i came
out i worked on new material
and then fell back on what i had that
worked so by the time the special came
out i was really close to having a whole
new act
it could tour right yeah so i never
decided i didn't stop
touring in that uh in that space as i
put together that new hour
you know i i i had this experience and
[ __ ] made my head explode
i was like telling these these just over
the top [ __ ] crazy stories which is
like what my stand-up is is comprised of
and
i was on stage performing the new
material
and i thought holy [ __ ] the [ __ ]
stories that i'm telling in this new act
pretty much all happened on camera so
what if i made my next special
multimedia so that you're not just
watching like me performing it's a show
but there's footage edited into it like
multimedia
for sure and as soon as i thought
multimedia stand-up comedy
like footage cut in i was like oh my god
i think this is going to be so [ __ ]
broadway brother very few yeah
very few comedians tell stories that are
true
you know and not only are mine true but
there's like footage to back up
like you know every absurd detail have
you ever seen uh
i think hassan minaj you know he had a
daily show correspondent and then when i
very first was getting a stand up
uh someone's like you should go see this
guy's show because i had an id
similar idea uh where you would have
graphics behind you telling your story
then you're doing stand-up but telling
the story at the same time
and behind you'd have video or pictures
from childhood well they go
there's a guy who's doing that right now
and so is hassan minaj won the first
show i've ever saw
and he does that it was a live show it
was so good man he's telling the story
of him being an
immigrant uh he's he's indian descent uh
immigrant and coming where he came from
and coming to america
he has all these pictures and videos
when he's a kid and coming over on the
boat
it's nuts man it's for sure
who yeah it was like uh it was like a
one-man show was so good
the way that i was doing this was was
all in in post though
you know i i let the stand up sort of
like
and then stand up and it's all right you
know and then do it in post
um and uh and what i did when i came up
with this idea i wasted no [ __ ] time
going and filming my shows and then
bringing in to the computer and cutting
it all together
this was the most transformative
thing and i couldn't have even seen it
coming but
up to that point i like like a lot of
comedians
cringed at the idea of watching footage
of
my there's nothing wrong it's just it's
there's it's you have to do it for your
special
i mean i doubt i was very interested in
that i hated it i was very involved in
the editing process
yeah i was very involved and it was it
was difficult yeah and that's
the most [ __ ] recklessly
irresponsible thing i think
a comedian can do is refuse to watch
footage of their performances you know
like i think that you have to
and all the top dogs do like rogan you
know with netflix usually they have
someone that
does the editing stuff like that rogan
does it himself
yeah i believe it you're talking he
spends days hours hours hours hours
weeks
editing making sure the cuts right the
angle is right yeah
and i refuse to watch footage of my
performances for like those first five
years
as soon as i came up with this idea and
now i'm cutting the footage in
then i'm on the computer yeah with
putting it all in the timeline sticking
the footage in
that forced me to study
my my act and you got you get better
from it
infinitely [ __ ] so so much because
there's so many everything that makes
you
cringe is that's that's a note there's a
reason yeah that's that's it that's a
note that you need to address
yeah and so i was like oh [ __ ] i hate
this this is this little
and i i just systematically addressed
all these things and the the progression
in my performing was was just sped up
so day and night right it's like this
because you know the right
the something that you're doing that's
not right that you're uncomfortable with
and you're like uh i i shouldn't be
doing that
right for whatever reason as soon as you
make that note then once the phone
the stage whatever the next night it's
gone it's still a gradual process but
god it speeds up so much
when you're when you're studying the
footage and and and cutting the footage
into it
it worked so well you know and do this
is like and
i've got footage where it's like the the
act was
it was largely a journey through my
criminal record
you know and i'm like i'm like i was out
on bail facing [ __ ] eight years in
prison
and that's when i flew over to europe
and got arrested again
yeah damn steven for international drug
smuggling and i have footage of me
doing all the international drug
smuggling getting arrested it's all on
camera
and like the stories are so [ __ ]
crazy and like uh i'm putting it all
together my head's exploding
it's just something this is so [ __ ]
dope you know and uh
what what happened then was i started
thinking well if there's anything i was
going to criticize about this act is
that it's
all like just so you know memory lane
[ __ ] like i don't want to spend the rest
of my life like
regaling the past you know so i was like
let me figure out
ways ways to plug so i let every bit in
the act
inspire something completely new like a
whole [ __ ] crazy
stunt you know so it's like an old story
and like because of that
i i decided to do this to nod
to that by doing this and uh
so now i'm plugging in all new [ __ ] you
know like new stunts and and
building that into the act and then i
was like okay so now that knobs coming
together so huge
now i need an an insane opening sequence
i knew i was going to film the special
in denver
but i got the whole jackass cast
together for the first time in in
it we hadn't all been together in one
spot since uh ryan dunn died yeah you
know
and this was like a very [ __ ]
significant thing
and we we did that in la i told the guys
i got like this billboard truck that
like with the ones that drive around las
vegas
and i made a billboard for the actual
comedy special itself even though i
haven't taped it yet
i've got the billboard for the [ __ ]
comedy special and there's a big space
we're gonna duct tape me to it
and i want you guys to do the taping to
take me to the side of this [ __ ]
billboard truck
do whatever the [ __ ] you want i don't
care just you know
that you had you have absolute open
season on me
and then once you get done taping me
this [ __ ] truck is going to drive
down the goddamn highway
you know i love it it must be dude
they're going man
i didn't know yeah full-on and uh and so
i mean under the tape we had a harness
but that was it like you know
transparent in the you know you see it
it's it's so gnarly
knoxville hit baseballs at me while i
was taped to this [ __ ]
that's funny he hit baseballs at me
so what so like
i would say obnoxious so so like
like horrifyingly hard like horrifying
like if they're like
i mean dude it's uh have a cup on
dude no nothing but a diaper
why would that be and so so we knew that
we knew that
uh like if they're getting out of la
that like it's just gonna be a bus ride
or they're gonna
so what we did was like when i got they
got done
taping me to the truck they mounted a
[ __ ] box
over me there's it looks like uh almost
like
like a coffin stuck to the side just
mounted over me so i was every bit duct
taped to the truck
but i put the box over me to get me out
of l.a
and then once we got to the [ __ ] what is
what's the town before barstow
we [ __ ] they unscrewed the box so i'm
just still taped
flying down the [ __ ] highway i don't
know if we went 100 miles an hour but
this is
whatever you know like yeah and uh we
went all the way to vegas
um until then and then once the sun came
down and then
we wrapped for the day and uh we picked
it up with the sun coming up
in uh colorado like colorado springs and
ever so we got the sun
so we just we pieced where did you guys
shoot in colorado uh
the gothic theater oh nice man yeah it's
a great place yeah and so dude it was so
symbolic too to have like the whole
jackass game because
when i got into stand-up it was they
weren't like mean to me
but it was like oh yes with your stand
up
and like it was like [ __ ] dude like i
you know you know
actually when i started doing standup it
was ryan dunn who was the most
supportive
you know he was like [ __ ] yeah you know
like bam was pretty i mean
they weren't like you know the guys who
are supportive i don't think people
realize it like means the world
like it means the world means everyone
else like come on dude
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
[Laughter]
grab that mic son